ann heish has been taken off life
support a week after her horrific car
crash
the 53-year-old actress was declared
brain dead on friday and she was held on
life support in order to donate her
organs
i would say to anybody you know go for
what you
feel truthfully in your life and you
will be rewarded a million-fold a rep
for ann said last week quote we lost a
bright light a kind and most joyful soul
a loving mother and a loyal friend in
the wake of anne's passing i just want
to say a few things anzac's husband
coley lefone mourned in on instagram
with a special tribute they shared an
adult son 20 year old homer i think ann
is probably
i'd like to think she's free free from
pain and enjoying or experiencing
whatever's next in her journey she was
brave and fearless loved really hard
goodbye anne
love you thank you thank you for all the
good times there were so many
and
see you on the other side and in the
meantime i got our son and he'll be fine
love you
and suffered a severe brain injury
significant burns and lung damage
vehicle into a structure we also have a
structure fire two-story single-family
dwelling
heavy smoke showing anne's blood work
also indicated she had narcotics in her
system at the time
but on saturday the lapd told et ann's
car crash is no longer under
investigation
[Music]
among the tributes from hollywood
pouring in
and swag the dog co-star robert de niro
you turned him around you turned him
around like a well they just hadn't
thought it through he tells e.t quote
she was a wonderful actress and i
enjoyed working with her tremendously i
also like acting in all different kinds
of things and starred in more than 40
movies and dozens of tv shows
i mean can't we can't we reattach it
somehow oh sure we'll like glue it back
on her latest role was playing a mom and
lifetime's girl in room 13. the movie
explores the world of human trafficking
hey something happened to her
bt spoke to the film's director
elizabeth rome and anne's co-star
larissa diaz
it's horrible what was it like for you
two to just hear
what had happened it was devastating and
i don't think we're done being
devastated
we come here with a very heavy heart to
not have her with us and we really know
that she was passionate about this film
to get it out there to people
to make an impact i've talked to ann
about this countless times and
we were both in it to make an impact and
to make a change